certes été au miles c'est vrai au soir
emmanuel merci d'être là avec nous on
voulait pas vous déranger
j'ai eu un prix le prix est ce que vous
connaissez
matthieu delormeau emmanuel macron là
excusez moi je ne regarde pas l'émission
mais de mon entourage me dit que vous
avez perdu les primaires face à monsieur
verdez
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai fréquenter les loosers mais
c'est vrai mais bon voilà c'était
c'était serré et on y avait soixante dix
30 bat mature et l'isi parlez-lui bas
bonsoir emmanuel sais pas ce que je peux
vous appeler manuel non mais manuel
n'est pas que je vous aime énormément je
voulais vous dire que vraiment vous avez
moderniser la politique vous vous vous
êtes beau vous êtes très talentueux vous
êtes notre nouveau inédit politique
est-ce qu'il est apolitique et à
d'autres nouveaux kennedy je me verrais
ce fut une bonne journée mais il parlait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais les pas de la personne voilà je me
proposais sans me vanter de peut-être ne
souhaite pas on ne vous souhaite pas la
même forme un homme a même proposé sans
me vanter peut-être d'être la nouvelle
jackie voilà ils veulent des guérillas
il veut des cas pas du tout non mais
doit on pas du tout géré en plus de
respect pour vous j'aimerais beaucoup
qu'on se pare donc je propose est peut
être qu'on prenne un verre dans un hôtel
parisien peut-être suite votre choix
commence par un bistrot vous viendriez
avec vos gardes du corps je viendrai
avec les miens c'est donc si vous avez
alors pardon messieurs dames au oui je
suis que le la dernière canicule
moi aussi c'est les vieilles que je les
colle en premier et je vais vous dire le
libérer ghoga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]